well that's about it for me I'm
pretty tired
rough week but before we get to some
news stories it's Friday so you know
what it's time for
Greg's leftovers
we should put a human head in there
I shouldn't even be telling you that I
should just do it it's leftovers where I
read the jokes we didn't use this week
and as always it's my first time reading
these so if they suck that's not my
fault it's on you
I Blame You all right here we go for the
first quarter of 2023 Delta Airlines
reported 360 million dollar loss and if
the company continues to lose money at
this rate they'll be legally required to
change their name to Bud Light
[Applause]
Anheuser-Busch
that's funny I just realized Bush
how ironic is that anyway
Anheuser-Busch has shed over 5 billion
in value since partnering with Dylan
Mulvaney making the making it the least
successful successful Duo since Alec
Baldwin teamed up with Smith
terrible
I couldn't even spit it out it's so bad
you know if I were an amateur I'd reread
that but I'm a pro
I'm a pro so I don't even care it's
Friday I'm half in the bag right now
the NYPD is rolling out crime fighting
autonomous robots to patrol Time Square
and Subways but officials say not to
worry the robots can't kill you unless
they fall into your bathtub
after it's not even logical after a
recent cameo in an episode of the
Mandalorian singer lizzo announced
she'll be appearing in another Star Wars
film this time as the Death Star
[Applause]
[Music]
a recent study claims climate change is
causing an increase in home runs in
Major League Baseball apparently the
reduced air pressure makes it easier to
stick a syringe in your ass
[Laughter]
I didn't see that one coming
yeah
all right according to a new survey one
in three children worry at least once
per week
and it's usually about the same thing
former ants
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so unfair
kid was at a party all right
former NC 2A swimmer Riley Gaines was
attacked by trans activists during an
appearance in San Francisco the police
didn't make any arrests but said if they
did bail would only be 80 percent of
what they'd charge a man
that's funny actually who wouldn't want
that Pennsylvania Senator John Fetter
men will return to the Senate next week
after an extended Hospital stay doctors
are confident he'll soon be back up to
40 percent
you know what you know why it took so
long for him to get out they were
waiting for a lightning strike
no Frankenstein I got it yeah no not
good no it was off the top of my head I
mean
basketball star Sue bird was among 40
professional athletes that signed a
letter opposing bands on men playing
women's sports proving even she can't
stand the WNBA
that's funny funny because it's true and
finally a recent study claims that
people who leave parties without saying
goodbye save up to two days per year
you could save up to five weeks per year
if you're not invited to parties at all
kill me
kill me always good for a punch line
that kill me now to the news
he's got a baby face and leaked it all
over the place and the penalty could be
severe for a man barely old enough to
buy a beer I speak is there a picture
coming up there you go I speak of 21
year old Massachusetts Air National
Guardsman Jack deshera who made his
first appearance in federal court today
he was the first defendant to actually
get carded
looking that young Joe Biden might deem
him sniffable
the uh the FBI busted Jack the dripper
yesterday over a leak of classified
documents that reportedly attempted to
undermine American efforts to help
Ukraine fight Russia or at least that's
what the government is telling us and
they're as believable as George Santos
to see someone mishandle intelligence
besides the bidens
it's reported the papers were first
posted online in January by someone on
Discord which is a social media Outlet
popular with video Gamers you know what
else is popular with video Gamers not
banging chicks
in your your face
oh yeah sorry Tulsi
I don't get it I don't get it I never
apologize yeah
meanwhile as more of your money flies
out the door and into Ukraine top KF
officials say this leak won't affect its
planned offensive against Russia which
begins as soon as Sean Penn arrives with
a fresh shipment of oscars to throw at
them
so like a few Wars we've already been
misled about we're repeatedly told by
the top that Ukraine is winning this war
against Putin but they've been telling
us that Russia is on the Rope since
Tulsi was a Democrat
who knows perhaps Jack may have exposed
info that shows what's really going on
in Ukraine that the U.S is more involved
than previously known and that Russia is
doing more than just holding on it's a
scary thought of the five outlets for
news on the war the media Ukraine Russia
the U.S or Jack
it's the barely legal leaker giving us a
necessary dose of reality it's almost as
if leaking is now what press briefings
used to be or supposed to be but maybe
if the government finally legalized
truth we wouldn't have to get it
illegally on the black market
here he is so Pete I had this weird
analogy that I came up with just an hour
ago it's a drug analogy if you can't get
legal drugs you go to the street if you
can't get truth from the government you
go to the leaks is that true or false
well that has been true for a long time
in our history I mean listen I don't
want to get the truth from someone
breaking the law and spilling secrets
that's not how you want it to go at the
same time we know we haven't been
getting it straight from the government
for a long time this doesn't surprise me
at all by the way I mean if you're who
do you think is in our military it's
young people yeah they've got they know
Tech they know so you're recruiting them
out to do that apparently he was an I.T
guy right which means he's got access to
everything including good meta
methamphetamines
the interesting part though is whether
or not
um he had a motive whether there really
was a motive right now he's being passed
off as this guy who want to look cool in
a chat room yeah and that's that motive
every night
it's not a bad motive exactly uh but
maybe there's more to it because we're
learning a lot about our things our
government's lying to us about I know
that it's like a binary question Tulsi
but I have to ask it is this guy would
you see him as a whistleblower or
somebody who betrayed his country or is
it something more complex uh you know I
think like Pete said we don't know much
about what his motives were any
information about him or his background
or anything else but I think we're we're
missing the real Scandal here which is
how much the mainstream media is working
to cover up the truth from the American
people of what is actually contained in
the information the documents that that
uh that he released you know they're
talking a lot about the documents but
not actually the information that was
there they can't even claim to be doing
it in the interest of National Security
because allies and adversarial
governments across the world have access
to that information but somehow we the
American people are not able to actually
know it and that's the real disservice
here is what what do you think that the
media I would say the corporate media
and I and I would include you know parts
of Fox as well are so it's not like
they're pro-war but if you if you just
raise a little bit of skepticism you get
that oh you're a Putin Putin lover and
it's just like okay that that is
designed to shut you up it is and so so
that's I've experienced that quite a bit
yeah let me let me let me let me explain
it for you guys
but it's like it's like you know don't
get mad at us because we're interested
in the leaks if you've been trying to
tell us to shut up forever about voicing
any curiosity exactly exactly I mean
that just speaks to the power of the the
unit party the war machine the military
industrial complex and how directly tied
the mainstream media is to that war
machine this is not the first time we've
seen this we saw it what was released in
the Pentagon papers we saw with the
Afghanistan papers how you know over two
decades the media covering up for the
military industrial complex and and so
this is the real problem here is that
when we have journalists who are
unwilling to do their job and tell the
truth then we have a real threat to
democracy because then we the American
people can't know really what's going on
you know cat they you know they say ah
this 21 year old he's only 21 how did he
get such you know reach and get such
information and I'm thinking like I
wouldn't even trust myself with it I'm a
world-class leaker you can't tell me
anything if you've if you've confided in
me on anything cat chances are everybody
already knows
I tell everybody in the audience I know
that's why when I I really want everyone
to know something I tell you and say
don't tell anyone yes
uh yeah I am a lot more interested like
Chelsea said in talking about the
contents of the leak than the leaker
because as we've all brought up this is
not the first time this has happened
when you know Afghanistan war it was
people lying and lying and lying about
how well it was going even though it
wasn't and it wasn't just that there was
no accountability for it it's that's how
you get promoted by telling people what
they want to hear so obviously some of
those same people are there the same
system is still in place so obviously
the same thing is going to be happening
and I I guess you could say oh it's you
know it's not my business but I don't
see how that is when we're all the ones
funding it so it kind of is our business
that's what pisses me yeah we we are and
I think the main thing that's changed is
that I am now able to say these things
on Fox news without people yelling at me
which they used to do when I said things
that were anti-war or skeptical of the
military-industrial complex but then now
because there's a Republicans who are
skeptical Democrats have now decided
that they need to be super pro-war just
because there's Republicans who are
questioning it it's like guys this is
what happens with a two-party system
where they just people just fight with
each other and then people are allowed
to get away with stuff like this and
this goes on and on and on and nothing
ever changes well
how big a problem how big a deal is this
story Tyrus it's not a big deal at all
yeah so he picked up some papers left on
the floor by our amazing Administration
are we really surprised
you know we shocked
it's Ted's doing
just like are we
are we surprised
that somebody walked in on his first day
in the job and said classified oh these
are going to be cool for my chat
they probably opened the door for him on
the way out and said hey kids pick those
up drop those ones over there so uh
nothing surprises me about quite
possibly the most
Equity friendly hiring Administration in
the history of stupidity so
literally they're like oh the world
leaders have it no they've been had it
they send it back what else you got this
is boring so uh not surprised although
I am shocked we can actually catch a
leaker that's amazing I thought because
for the last four years they were like
impossible right right and we still
haven't figured out who made the rookie
wage even if you did catch him it was
racist yeah yeah so I'm nice to see
we've come along or you just call him
something else like Alexander vinman is
a hero yes this guy's a zero got it a
nice little rhyme there well we don't
know what number he identifies with Pete
that's true
that's good
you get the feeling last year point that
we'll move we'll go move on but it's
like there does feel like there's cracks
in the foundations of everything and I I
racks yeah but I they being wide
that I could break dance through with
three of my buddies at my side that'd be
fun to watch would touch each other but
it is do you think it has something to
do with the book putting everything
before ahead of confidence yeah when you
hire people based on how they look this
is what happens yeah so how about when
you can't recruit anybody in the
military right now yes what does the
military do lowers the standards you're
gonna get that crack's gonna get the
crack's gonna get wider
you know all right we're done we're done
we're done
up next
he drifting drag to get chess money in
his bag hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else